hundreds of indigenous protesters took
to the streets of atalaya do no
they demanded justice for indigenous
expert bruno pereira and british
journalist don phillips they went
missing a week ago while they were
returning from an expedition to the
javadi valley reservation
home to the largest number of
uncontacted tribes in the world
where are bruno and dom they chanted but
the demonstrators also denounced the
onslaught they have been suffering from
illegal fishermen poachers loggers and
miners
bruno pereira had been helping them
patrol their territory and map the
invasions dom phillips was accompanying
him on a trip to finish writing a book
on how to save the amazon
on sunday after a week-long search
divers retrieved a plastic bag from the
river containing a backpack and some
belongings of the two missing men
relatives say the backpack contained a
computer all belongings socks shirts
shorts their work tools such as their
laptops reports on monday morning that
two bodies had also been found or denied
by brazil's federal police
brazil's president jaibo sonaro said he
thought something evil had happened to
them
the evidence leads us to believe that
something bad was done to them because
human viscera were floating in the river
indigenous leaders we spoke to said they
will keep up the pressure to find out
what happened to dom phillips and bruno
pereira and that they will continue the
patrols that pedera organized to help
protect the rainforest
monica yanaikeval jazeera rio de janeiro